of course NATO are meeting as we speak
so we just wanted to start with a little
snapshot here of the Ukraine the NATO
members uh in blue and just uh ask the
question what's probably top of the
agenda in the discussions that they've
been having over the last few hours so
this is an emergency meeting to talk
about Ukraine and there are there are
two important Dimensions to this
conversation the most important in the
longer term is how NATO now remobilizes
itself to deal with Russia under
President Putin in a way that is the
most significant change since the end of
the Cold War in 1990 and the second
thing they're going to do just as
important is talk about NATO supports to
Ukraine in terms of more sanctions and
Military Support on the topic of
military support if we just dive in a
little bit closer but still with the
NATO neighbors clearly in shot some
announcements that that have started to
come out some that are expected in terms
of reinforcements yes so NATO is going
to affirm today it's going to deploy
four more battle groups it has battle
groups already deployed uh across nato
in one each to Slovakia Hungary Romania
and Bulgaria and they're a sign of NATO
assurance and a signal that article 5
remains invalid and now let's uh dive in
a little bit to get some perspectives of
what's going on on the ground in Ukraine
first of all a focus dive on Kiev itself
and we have heard relatively encouraging
stories of some Successful
counter-attacks by Ukrainian forces in
and around Kiev are those significant
generals Richard so so they are
significant but they're very small scale
so we know of successful Ukrainian
contracts for example in European and
Butcher and also actually to the east of
Kiev and these are very small tactical
actions but they are indicative of the
Russian forces are not breaking into
Kiev and indeed in many places are
moving back a little and starting to
build defensive positions and that feels
like another signal of this evolving
stalemate Let's uh talk about that cell
mate if we zoom out and look at uh all
of uh Ukraine we've been talking that
these red shaded areas the land that
Russia has seized haven't changed
drastically over the last week the
fourth week of this war the stalemate is
is that a very good thing for Ukraine or
does it get Russia time to to refuel
both literally and metaphorically well
both of those things are are true I
think is is I think the signs are right
now that the Russian campaign in its
current construction is not capable of
taking much more ground and we're
beginning to see Russia dig in these
defensive positions which would indicate
that it it realizes that that does not
mean that that will be the outcome
because Russia is moving reinforcements
from across Russia both men and material
in order to unlock that stalemate but
we're seeing not much movement around
Kiev we're seeing the battle for Mario
poll which I I we imagine they will in
the end uh break we have not seen the
significant movement towards Odessa that
we were forecasting a week ago but we
couldn't rule it out and we are
concerned about Russian forces moving
from the North and the South of the
country once Mario Paul is concluded in
order to try and circle Ukrainian forces
in the in the donbass but what this
begins to feel like is a war confined to
the east of Ukraine except for
continuing air and missile attacks in
the West on the supply lines but this is
not the war Russia intended to have